today at firebase summit a big new
feature was announced firebase
extensions imagine if the cloud had
something like a wordpress plug-in
system where you can install or opt in
to specific features based on the needs
of your application and with this
initial release we have nine plugins
that handle things like image resizing
distributed counters transactional email
and more and once again firebase has
made a bunch of my past videos obsolete
I'm not too english Masshole career so
today i want to show you how to not
write code by using firebase extensions
if you're new here like and subscribe
and consider becoming a pro member at
bioship i/o and if you're serious about
building apps on the firebase platform
to get started you'll need to have a
firebase project and if you go down here
to the bottom you'll see a new option
for extensions let's go ahead and
install the first one we see to resize
images now unfortunately for me about a
year ago I created a video about
resizing images with a cloud function
but this extension provides the exact
same functionality with no effort on my
part and it's tested and maintained by
these smart people at Google let's go
ahead and click install and you'll see
it takes us to a page to configure the
extension the first thing it'll have you
do is review the architecture or API is
enabled by this extension when it comes
to image resizing you'll need to have a
cloud storage bucket and then a cloud
function to handle the resizing after a
file is uploaded to that bucket go ahead
and click Next and then it will have you
review the access granted to the
extension firebase will automatically
create the appropriate service account
that has IM roles assigned for whatever
resources this extension needs in the
third step is where we configure and
customize the behavior of the extension
in this case we'll go ahead and have it
generate thumbnails for 200 500 and 1000
pixel sizes and we'll go ahead and
specify a directory in the bucket named
thumbs which is where the thumbnails
will be saved it will take a few minutes
to install because what it's doing under
the hood is deploying a cloud function
to your project after it's complete
you'll be able to review the
configuration details and then if you go
to the functions tab you'll see that
cloud function deployed in your
functions list and if you're really
interested in how the function works
under the hood you can go to the GCP
console - cloud functions click the
source tab and then you can see the full
source code for the function and all of
the extensions are open sourced so you
can see them on github as well and
hopefully in the near future they'll
open the system 2/3
party developers meaning you could
extend and potentially monetize the
firebase platform as a developer but I'm
really just speculating there I have no
idea if or when that'll happen so now
that we have this extension installed
let's go into our storage bucket and
upload a file there and see what happens
you can see our storage bucket is
completely empty and I'll go ahead and
upload the cover image for this video
after the upload is complete we'll go
ahead and refresh the page and you'll
now see we have a Thums directory here
that has magically resized this image to
the sizes that we specified so if you
have an app that handles high resolution
file uploads this extension gives you an
incredibly simple pipeline for resizing
and optimizing those images now let's go
ahead and take a look at a second
extension that makes a another one of my
videos obsolete and that is the
translate text extension this particular
extension works with Google's cloud
translation API and that is a paid API
although it does have a free tier so you
need to at least have a billing account
set up and be on the blaze plan for this
firebase project we can go ahead and
follow these same steps as before but
I'm also going to add Japanese and
Arabic language codes to the
translations and there's over 800
different language codes for you to
choose from
now this extension will be looking for a
collection and firestore will go ahead
and call that comments and then when
that document is created it will look at
the text field on the document and then
translate the text into an object called
translated let's go ahead and give that
a couple minutes to install and then
head over to the firestore database will
create the comments collection add a
document to it that has a text property
on the document and after its created it
should automatically translate that text
[Music]
now this should happen in a matter of
seconds but nothing actually happened
here so what went wrong our firebase
extensions broken or did I do something
wrong we can find out by going to the
cloud function logs what you'll notice
is that most of the translations ran
properly except for the Japanese
language code and so this was actually
my fault
JP is not the proper language code it's
actually J a and I wanted to show you
this because extensions aren't failsafe
if you don't add the right configuration
options they won't work properly we can
fix the issue by going back to the
extension tab and reconfiguring the
extensions parameters I'll just go ahead
and change the language code from JP to
J a and then we just have to wait a
couple minutes for those changes to
propagate or for the underlying cloud
function to be redeployed now if we go
back to firestore and add a new comment
to the comments collection you'll see it
translates the text and no more than two
seconds so it is incredibly awesome to
just enable that kind of feature with a
click of a button now I have to admit
that building a translation feature from
scratch really isn't that big of a deal
it's just a simple API call that you can
make from your back-end code so the
translation extension is really just a
minor convenience in my opinion however
something that's not so trivial is
setting up a distributed counter when
you have an extremely high volume of
writes going to a single document
so normally firestore limits you to
about one write per second which you can
burst above but what if you have a
social media app and you have an
extremely viral post that's generating
10,000 likes per second handling a
massive volume of writes like that would
require you to shard the database and
also carefully aggregate the count
across those shards needless to say it's
not exactly an easy process but now
there is an extension for that let's go
ahead and install the distributed
counter extension and it's going to
install three different cloud functions
in this project then after the
installation is finished there will be a
few additional steps to take on your
part in this particular case you'll need
to update your firestore security rules
so that right access is granted to that
shards collection and then it will also
give you a command to run to set up a
cron job in your Google cloud platform
project and its job is to ping the
controller function to make sure that
these shards are scaled properly and
last but not least it gives you a script
that you can use in your front-end code
so it's also extending the firebase job
script SDK now this is a feature that's
not required by a lot of apps but if
your app is seeing a huge volume of
Rights you'll probably want to get this
implemented very quickly because it
means your app is scaling up quickly and
having something packaged up and ready
to go like this is extremely valuable
I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things up
there I feel like I don't have much else
to talk about because extensions are
just so easy but in the future we'll
look at some more complex examples with
actual front-end framework integrations
and make sure to let me know what you
think about firebase extensions in the
comments thanks for watching and I will
talk to you soon
[Applause]
[Music]